We're going to be jumping back into our back test, picking up our
left off. We are now on the 1st of March. So we're doing March
with this. So let's see, we do have any news today. So 1st of
March, ISM 10, and anything for London, we have. Okay. So for
London session, we have at the end of London session, inflation
rate, and we also have full year GDP growth and government
budget. So full year GDP growth and government budget aren't
something that you that you see consistently. Inflation rate
quite consistent, but still inflation rate year on year. So
I would expect again, for the most part, your own news doesn't
really impact your $2 too much. But when you do have inflation
rate, or you do have, I don't really know what full year GDP
growth is going to do or government budget. But I would
assume given that they aren't always there, they're going to
be fairly significant. So I want to keep my eyes on this. I
pretty news aggressive day. So if I have a news aggressive day,
I obviously do want to treat my day a little bit differently. So
if I have, for example, like right now, we're in a large trading
range, right? And again, I'll do my best to try to make this
March testing, not as long as fabs. So I want to spend too much
time kind of waffling. But when we're in a large range like
this, and there's a little bit of kind of, I want to say
confusion, but it's just not, it's not clean. This isn't a
clean range. You know, we have swing low, swing high, and then
internally, we're at this point, bearish, right? This low down
here has been being broken. It will let me select it. Right?
And we're kind of coming off the highs in here to these lows
and pulling back up in here. Prices aggressively bearish. So
it's it's a little bit tricky. So when you have days like this
where it's aggressive, new stuff like this, I just want to
place purely just intraday momentum. I don't want to try and
swing for the fences, right? I don't want to try and hold the
position up for swing highs, for example, because I don't want to
hold through a kind of a large book of news, unless I'm super
clear on kind of a high timeframe bias, for example, which I'm
not. So yeah, let's go to London session anyway. Let's kind of
see what we have. So again, you know, the swing lows are down
here. And these equal lows, they're relative equal, but we've
already taken this low. So we have a liquidation at least. So
we're bullish from a structure perspective. But again, like I
said, like, I don't want to bet on taking all these highs in here.
I know it's possible. But it's not really what I want to bet on
like the fact that we're sitting in this range as well for an
extended period of time again, I said I don't want to waffle. But
if we kind of have some context of a higher timeframe, you can see
that we've broken down this lower, we've had to pull back and
with the fact that we're sitting in this range for a while and
now beginning to head downwards, it looks to me like this is
probably going to expand lower. I could be wrong as well. But
that's how it looks my high timeframe perspective as well.
So I want to be again, high timeframe is something that I'm
super reliant upon, at least just for this specific model. Again,
another thing you have to understand is like, there are
models, there are playbooks. And then there's your
interpretation of how you want to play that playbook or how you
want to trade it. And that, that genuinely becomes solely your
responsibility. My responsibility is to give you a playbook
that I know works and make sure you understand it well enough.
And more importantly, in the process well enough on how to
actually build an edge. What you then do with that is your
responsibility. I will always be there for support. I will always
guide you. I'm always, you know, kind of preach to you the
inner edge and the importance of psychology and the importance
of an operating system. But the reality is, is what you do with
that is up to you. If you take that and then you want to refine
it, change it at higher time frames, move it up time frames.
It's my, my goal to give you the building blocks to be able to
go ahead and do that and refine it yourself. Hey, maybe this
playbook, you know, it's profitable. It will make you money,
but maybe it doesn't suit your trading style. Maybe it doesn't
suit your lifestyle. Maybe you want to go to a higher time
frame. Maybe, you know, I don't know, whatever you want to do.
The purpose of this is not just to give you a playbook, it's to
give you how you want to read price. And so sometimes even if
we jump out of live sessions, for example, I, I may have my own
nuanced interpretations of price action. And I might take trades
off of my own kind of discretion or my own, you know, opinion
that's outside the balance of playbook. But that's my
responsibility. That's my choices. As long as you have a
playbook that you know works, and you have the ability to build
your own edges as well as already having edges that are proven
profitable. That's my job. Okay, I already said I don't want to
make this as long as February. So let's just kind of jump in.
I'm going to look for longs. Plain and simple. Frankfurt has
swept Asia session low. Okay, a lot of fair value gap in here.
So, you know, we might at least help us to run these
highs. But again, I'm going to treat this session. Is that
that straight changing character. Okay. So shift bullish, shift bullish, no
pull back,
no pull back, no pull back, no pull back, no pull back. So this is, the M1 is
already bullish,
right? So what we have here is an already bullish M1 that we are pretty much
ready to trade.
So if the M1 is already bullish, when we're coming in for our setup, we can
just look at this here
as internal. So this break here that comes during London session, this is
pretty much an
internal realignment with the already external bullish order flow. The area
that I'm looking at
is here as well, obviously a huge move to the upside. It is again a news day,
so I want to be,
you know, only be too aggressive, but we have the range, the expansion, then we
have the accumulation.
So the accumulation really happens here, right? Range, sweep, range, expansion.
So this is really the area that we want to see price trade back into.
Is this, right? It's a very, very, very small stop loss, man, I missed those
days.
And what high is this? So we could literally just play M1 continuation and
pretty much take five
far. Again, it's a news day as well. I don't want to hold my position. I think
we already said
that I don't want to hold my position and expect price to rally all the way up
to the highs in here
because I've already said what my opinion is. But let's play price order by 1%
of current balance.
So we're also at break even as well. Cool. I'm going to play this by ear, see
if we even get tagged
in what time is it, 2.30, news is at five. Okay, that's a tag. It's a decent
reaction.
That's a mitigation. Did I set it only at five or? I did. I would have also
liked to have extended
this as well. That's five or I would have liked to have some of the position
open up to this high as well.
3 a.m. I was supposed to play out. 3.45.
I would have hit break even. I wouldn't have had myself to break even anyway.
How do we have held position for the highs?
4.10. Those lows are definitely getting taken. Oh, no. Okay. Fair enough.
So, yeah. Probably got to stop that break even anyway if I had tried to hold
the rest of this position.
I'll take that again. Like I said, that's 5 a.m. That's our target hit in as
well in news,
which I don't want to do that. I don't want to rely on news to have to do that.
Again,
for any of you guys trading prop firms, certain prop firms, if you're trading
CFD prop firms,
for example, you may not be able to even do that. So, understand that the
nuance is required.
For this position, 5R is more than worthy. It's more than worthy. You don't
have to be greedy,
especially on a day like this. So, what if price runs up? Well, we're going to
have more news in
like 20 minutes. That's that same 5 a.m. candle, isn't it? That's the real move
. That's the
liquidation. That's what does liquidate the high. There you go. There's the
liquidation,
and there's the real moves off the back of the inflation rate. Inflation rate
was higher
than anticipated than forecasted, sorry, only slightly, but still higher.
That's why we had a lot of prices. And then let's, I want to, I'm interested to
see what
happens with this government data that are coming out right now. Hmm, less than
really.
Okay, it was more so the actual inflation rates.
Okay, New York session. Still, still technically bullish.
I don't like all this sell-side liquidity, to be honest with you, but again, I
'm not
traded in anything discretionary at the moment. For me, I would need to see
price trade back into
back into this area of, oh, I need to tag this previous trade.
M15 point of interest. We had a sweep of Asian lows. M1 was already bullish. We
ended off an M5
and M1 order block. Didn't need to close half because we had news.
No trading on session, but with CPI. No, don't end up before we tell sales. No.
Playbook followed setups. This is a Frank Frankfurt sweep reversal. That is
where Frankfurt
sweeps Asia and the reversal happens in London session. Point of interest.
It's really a broad point of interest, right? This entire range is there of
interest.
The refined area would be here and that would be weak, but it's a broad
session is London. Trend is still changing character. We're still inside this
price like,
I don't like it. I want to get out of this price like, structure flow. We are
internally
bearish. So internal is counter. Are we in premium discount? Yes, very much so.
News closed before high impact. Execution window.
The trade was queued between 2 to 3am. And again, if you need to add notes,
you can. I just don't need to. Cool. New York session. So I would like to see
we have the low sweep on Asia, but I need to see price pull back to an area of
interest.
If we can get that.
All right, what time is it? 9.20. It's not worth entering.
We have ISM.
They should be like 30 minutes away and I don't want to hold through that. That
's ISM.
Awesome.
Still, we're still in this price like, oh, we're still bullish.
And we're still entirely bearish. So entirely bearish from these highs.
Okay, so we're looking for longs again. What day is it? Fourth of March, Monday
.
I think it's a news free day. It is. So no news today, which is cool.
Pretty simple. I need to see sweep of Asia lows.
Swing high as well, by the way, is all the way up here.
I don't like this range, but it just goes to show that you can trade inside of
ranges,
as long as you're managing risk. Is that sweep of Asia?
No confirmation. And then that session done. Let's go to New York session.
Let's see equal highs. So as of right now, we're looking to sweep this low.
If we don't have a POI created in here, I can't enter this trade because it
just doesn't make sense.
And that's that session done. So let's go to London session. That's Tuesday,
the 5th of March.
Let's see what we have. Dum, dum, dum, dum, dum, dum.
ISM at 10. So again, for this specific set up here,
the London session level, it didn't really give us anything, right? So it doesn
't
break anything. If this London level had broken this high,
and we come back into here, I could have traded this, but it didn't. But now we
can look
longing from here. Do we have any news? We do. Just ISM. Is that the only thing
that we have?
Yeah, cool. Let's take a look at this. So now we can trade.
We're still bullish, all right. Yep.
So we already swept in Frankfurt.
Let's see.
Okay, I need to have a little bit more detail here.
Okay, so we're bearish. We're bearish. M1.
This is why detail is really important.
Sometimes it really requires it. Sometimes not so.
So we shift bullish here. We don't have up over.
And then we break the lows here. Yeah, so we are, we're bearish. The actual
swing high is up here.
So again, we can't be trading this because we are bearish, right? The shift
that we need to see is
a buy side. Probably not going to get up. Let's just play out 15 minutes.
Okay, that could be a new leg. So we shift lower. What time is it?
Could still get into trade here. We broke this high.
We do. 315. Cool. Now we can look at taking this position.
So we have no news in New York. Where are we looking at trading from?
So again, paying attention to detail in the order flow. Let's look at the one
minute time frame.
What we can see here is the price sells off. We have a reversal here with
aggression.
Price comes back in, mitigates this old area of demand that push price higher,
comes back in, mitigation and continuation. So the expectation is for price to
come back
into this level. Probably refine it to this final load up area. And then let's
have a look at rest
reward. If we use this, for example, maybe we use this larger contextually.
Ideally, you
want to see this area taken. It's not an ideal.
So here we're on the 15 minutes. So maybe we could do the 15 minutes on mitig
ates. So sometimes
it may seem to come to a 15 minute. And you see there, the 15 minutes actually
on mitigate.
So we can use the 15. Just about playing between these time frames on the
sandwich is
bare as well. That's a really nice value gap. If this 15 minute candle is
finished, I don't know if
it has yet. Has it? Yeah, it has. And that's a four one to four. So if I move
it up to here,
for example, that would actually give us a one to five.
We have ISM later. We can manage it if we need to manage it. But I also
understand that one
to five is here. So I definitely want to be close and positionally here as well
.
That's why I would look up. Press text in. Okay, price shifts the highs.
We do still technically have unmitigated area in here. What time is it?
450 and news is... Wait, Friday or Tuesday. Fifth news is at 10. So dumb, dumb,
dumb, dumb, dumb.
Okay, I'm pretty much looking to keep this position open for now. I want to put
my stop
loss just under here. So at least I can cut off maybe 30% of my risk.
Price goes back down. New obsession opens. And then we get stops out here.
So for me, and that's ISM. So again, for me, like,
price comes back in. Once we move above this area, we'll have ISM.
But I already would have taken out the lows here.
I wish I had my stop swap. Yeah, for me, that's a position well managed.
The actual loss could have been 5 and the actual loss was what do we cut off it
,
cut off 2. So I ended up cutting off around 30% of that position, I think.
Which is good management for me. Okay, so we're M15 pro trend. We have a sweep
of liquidity.
M1 change character. Yeah, M1 or M5. All the block that I got. Yeah, break of
low. Yeah.
No trading on session with CPI. Don't annotate before we start else.
Playbook followed. The setup. So this is a, this is a Frankfurt
sweep, but London technically from a sweep Frankfurt. So London sweep Frankfurt
reversal.
So London sweep Frank. Cool. Point of interest. Are we coming from an area of
interest?
Yes, we are. It's a strong area of interest. Session is London.
Trend is still in this damn change of character phase. Structural flow.
So at the time of taking the trade, it's internal bearish. Premium discount, no
news.
No news. Trade's already done before the news. Execution window
was 345. So between 3 and 4am. Cool. Let's move on. So again, sometimes you can
get the right
trade idea, but you might just get something like that. That's just the way the
game goes.
Let's close this. Let's go to Wednesday. London session. Okay. A lot of
liquidity below these
levels. That's the first thing that, that come straight to my, my mind is this
entire area is
just liquidity. Wednesday six. Do we have any news Wednesday six? We do balance
of trade,
not really bothered. We have joke, job openings and fed. We have power
testimony. They're above
at 10. So again, really want to be cautious of, of that. But I want to look at
trading long.
That's for sure. Already in this area of interest. I don't think we're going to
get
super Asia. We couldn't get people this liquidity actually. Let's see. But we
're only looking for
longs. We're just continued. Okay. And then New York is going to give us
nothing because I don't
want to be looking at anything until this age low has been taken. What happens
with power?
Price moves. But now we've taken out this short or high, right? We have here.
So
we ended up respecting the structural, structural range. Fair enough. And now
we continue higher.
Now we're in another large trading range. The reality is this price is
definitely going to
come back into at least this area. Another large trading range. No problem.
Star of London. So we're looking at longs. It's just said that we have, oh,
okay, we don't want
to be trading New York today. So at New York, we have ECB's interest rate
decision, deposit rate
facility and press conference. That's at New York Open, not New York Open 815
to 845. And then
we have Powell speaking again. So we can look at getting into position and see
kind of how that
differs. We're looking for longs, obviously. We're looking for longs below this
price point.
Pretty much. Can we get a reversal? That looked like a reversal to me.
It is indeed coming in entry. So five minute is a little bit noisy, three
minute noisy,
one minute noisy. So when you have some, like this is probably about a 15
minute,
and I'll just go look to the 15 minute and see if I can get something. So
obviously I'm looking at
this cell, this cell before the buy momentum comes in. I want to cover that. I
'm going to need
a really large, not too aggressive above the highs. I'm going to close the full
position at 5R
because there's no reason for price to go. There's no target other than that.
But yeah, I'll go with
basically this M5 aggressive manipulation candle before the bullish move.
That's what I'm looking for. That's a tag 420 price moving, but we still have
unmitigated prices in here.
That's not mitigated. It needs to be very careful with this New York session.
That's 750, 7.45. Okay, so we're about to get, we're about to have ECB deposit
facility rate
and their interest rate decisions. So
let's see, all these parts are aggressively bullish.
Okay, they're aggressively bullish,
but it is also just unnecessary risk.
We're at breakeven as well.
I'm just going to close the position.
I like the syrup. That's the annoying part.
We're extremely bullish.
How can I manage risk?
So that's 1%. If I bring my stops up to here, I reduce my risk to 0.7%, but you
could also get
a slippage. If I close half of my position, I immediately go half risk
and go into this basically trading news, which isn't really ideal is it?
It's not. This could go either way. I don't actually know which way it's going
to go.
Cool. We'll close the entire position at pretty much breakeven.
It's like a excuse. It's better to be, it's essentially just gambling if I'm
not going to close
the position. I do think the price of trade higher, but it doesn't make sense.
M15 pro trend,
yeah, no need for entry return. Realistically, in some sense, I haven't
actually followed the
management of this, but in essence, I am because I'm closing the trade before
the news comes out.
Tags, this is a London sweep Asia, point of interest.
No, I would say empty leg. Session, London trend is confound reversal,
structural flow.
But I already have a structural flow. That's not true. Yes, we do.
Counter trend, we're definitely not in the previous discount. News, yeah, close
before high impact.
Execution window.
Four to five. Cool. Now let's see how things play out.
Good decision. To make sense, if I don't close that position at breakeven, I'm
gambling.
It's plain and simple, because I actually don't have an edge. I don't
understand what's going to come out of there.
What about off the back of this now?
It could still technically long. When's the next event? 845.
And then power as well. Yeah, there's not going to be another opportunity here.
Even still, I'm not only attacked. Cool.
Sometimes that is just how the game goes.
From a logical rule based perspective, I technically could have traded this,
because it is
my execution is like 30 minutes after news and an hour before news.
But the reality is, is if I was in the market live in the moment, I probably
wouldn't even show up
to this price action knowing what's going to happen today.
I would rather trade it how I'm going to trade it as opposed to just
purely just following the rules. And then one may even argue that
would I have maybe taken my entry here and then missed a tag anyway. So it
doesn't really matter.
Let's keep it moving. 8th of March. I am 34 minutes in. I'm 7 days in. I'm
doing it again,
aren't I? Okay, I'm going to go faster. So now it's going to be the 8th of
March.
And FB.
Yeah, I don't really want to trade.
On an FB day. We're extremely bullish.
I don't really want to trade on an FB day.
They're bullish, right?
Hmm.
We're technically bullish, but I don't want to trade on an FB day.
Just doesn't make sense because now I have to hold this position.
No, I'm not going to trade it.
No, I'm not going to trade after an FB by either. It's got to London.
So again, trade avoided if there is a setup and there is a set to be honest.
I'm not sure if there's a three can I pull back here, actually?
No.
Oh, maybe. Yeah.
Technically, probably would have ended up breaking even anyway, if it was a
token.
But again, in an ideal world, I don't want to show up to the markets on an FB
day.
I don't have an edge.
We're still bullish.
We are really aggressively in just the middle of nowhere at this point.
This is our swing low, although I would like to use this, but this is our swing
low.
Just swing high. So pretty much look at the longs. If we can sweep below Asia
and look for
longs, that would be considered a nice sell for me. Here's London Open.
So we have Frank first sweeps Asia.
So let me just make sure I'm clear on my structural levels.
I need to look closer because I'm still not clear.
Okay.
We swapped Asia.
Now we're having the break.
Now we can look at the longs.
Not the cleanest surprise action I was really.
Because there's two areas I could enter here. I could enter on you.
And cover the lows. What's the risk reward on that?
One to five with price rates up here.
Don't like this liquidity to be honest with you, but do you have news what day
is it?
Monday 11th of March. Do we have actual news?
No, we don't. Wait, hold on a second.
10th of March, daylight saving changes. That's seven till 10.
That's nine. That's nine till one. So 10th of March, daylight saving changes,
this has to be changed.
Because New York goes from, so you can see here that the times have changed,
obviously,
like on Sunday the 10th of March it becomes nine. Here it's eight.
But you can see it still saves as UTC minus four.
So trading view automatically does it, but your indicator won't.
So this needs to now be changed to if age was one till five.
So let's go forward. It doesn't need to be zero to midnight. That's zero to
four, sorry.
That becomes eight to midnight. Yeah, so everything goes back now.
So New York goes 11 to two.
And London becomes six to nine.
Okay, that would have been a lot cleaner as well. That makes more sense.
2am, 11, 12, sorry, it's eight.
Can I just make sure of that?
No, yeah, it must be.
Because UTC change is right.
Tuesday, well, I'll know for absolute sure on tomorrow at eight thirty.
So let's see, apologies for the UNL. Okay, where do I look at it and enter this
position?
Okay, and sometimes sometimes you'll see me do this because it's the only way
that I can get
clarity. So for me, I would be really looking at this, this final kind of range
before the
liquidation. This is the area that I would be looking at. First and foremost,
one to five.
It's going to be here. We can deal with that. I have no news as well. Okay,
order. So we'll go
limit here. That's my actual target, but I'll be taking profits.
Up in this region. Let's see if we get tagged in. Wait.
I didn't move myself, let me cancel that.
Okay, cool. We shall see what we get.
Tag pressure is out. And stops. No. I'll just do that again.
That should be a break, even.
I should pay more attention.
That's pretty lucky. My position should still be open, right? Okay, so it's so
open. Now pay
close attention. That's a break, even. The close above this high is stops the
break, even.
Is there a reason the price would need to come back to this area? Potentially,
yeah.
The sell to buy is mitigated, but potentially, yeah. So what we can do in this
scenario is just
move our stops below this low. M15.
Yeah, I think it makes sense. Move the stops there.
So we reduce risk by literally 50%. We already know the outcome of it, but it's
not about the
outcome. It's about just literally following the process. Price comes back in.
Again, also,
I'm on our own price action in real time as well. So now we've mitigated this
area,
right? And we're expanding below it. We've mitigated this area, right? You can
quite clearly see
that if that family kind of doesn't exist, we come into this area, we trade
immediately straight
out of the area. And in doing so, that gives us a new area. And so each time
price should not be
disrespected. These price likes, because if one of them is going to get dis
respected,
they're all going to get taken from liquidity. So again, the same thing becomes
a thing literally.
Like if these levels are getting respected, you don't want to be sitting here
with price
gravitating your area like this. That's the first thing. The first thing is a
real good trades.
Usually you're going to get the momentum from those positions pretty much
immediately.
And you want to be able to be kind of dynamically managing your risk, right? So
when price comes
back in and tags us in, and then takes us out, we should be going to break even
. We can't
get to break even because this area of price is still unmitigated. So price
comes back in,
mitigates the price, expands back out. So now you can look here, adjusting it
again,
because this area is now being collected. So price doesn't need to revisit this
area.
It gets collected, price trades out of this level, leaves again another area of
price that
may want to be respected. What happens, price comes back into it and has a
reaction. And then
the area of price that's going to be respected again becomes in here. And so
again, I'm essentially
just layering off my risk because number one, when I'm in the position like
this,
and price isn't running, I already have level of doubt. The fact that price is
just stacking up lows,
price shouldn't need to disrespect these lows. If price needs to disrespect
this low,
the reality is, is it's going to manipulate the rest of the lows. And sure,
there'll be times
where price might come into here and then continue trading higher, but it's
just a probability.
Price comes back in again. Same thing. Look at this. There's no such thing as
coincidences,
coincidences, just something that someone says when they don't understand what
's happening.
We get tagged in, price goes to break even. We don't go to break even because
this is
unmitigated. Price comes back in, mitigated, expands out of it. So these orders
get executed,
price goes higher. Now we move our stop below this low because this is the area
that's in control.
Price trades out, we come back into this area and then we begin expanding out
again. So we move our
stop. Price comes back in, expands out. Now we're at break even. There's no
need for price
to come all the way back down. I'm just skipping things too fast. I want to
make sure that we're
actually going as I would be going in real time. I need to make sure I'm
playing one minute price
action as well. There was a never trade as well that objectively speaking, I
would have went
break even on if I've traded it live. So I need to slow things down. Again,
price is coming back
into this level and it expands out. I don't need to go and put my stops below
this low. Like,
can I? Yeah, sure, but it's going to make a like a huge difference. It ends up
being
you end up taking like, I don't know. I don't know what that is for a racial
war perspective.
But again, I don't want it to interfere with the the data of win rate and stuff
. So I'm going to
give it a break even. The moment that one of these fails, right? Now this level
is,
now this level has failed us. Price should not be sitting around this level in
here and then
starts to come back down because if it does, now all of this becomes liquidity
because price
couldn't take higher. So sellers obviously came out on top, right? Have another
reaction.
Price shouldn't be getting progressively lower. And then look, this goes for a
liquidity run.
The moment it hits these low, all of these stop losses get triggered. And we
were just
fortunate to make sure that we're out before this liquidity gets breached
because our liquidity
is with this liquidity. Okay, like just attention to detail. Okay, that's
general.
I'm an hour in a game and I'm not even halfway through. I need to hurry up. And
now I follow my rules.
you
you.
So we do have news, but it's not until New York, but it is pretty substantial.
So it's 345 now.
And we do have.
inflation rate.
And then, of course, we're probably not going to move that.
So that's it. Yeah, we had CPI. Now we have a new short to arrange, still
respect to this
construction.
Okay, and another project.
If I'm being silent, it's just I'm going to focus and just tell you the details
that you need to
understand and let's try out.
you.
you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you you
you you you you you
you.
and five five I got.
it's good.
I was here in some while I did entry so I got broken I keep it open because
there's still the
entirety that I got. We come back and we react. We come back and we sweep again
aggressive move
to the sell side. That's my confirmation that like price shouldn't be trading
above this high
unless it's going to trade above this high climate simple. That's how we're
able to reduce these
the the significance in losses. We were part of a trend but we did sweep on the
highs.
you.
So we're like six weeks in and we are up 3.2% not the greatest trading
conditions to be honestly
quite difficult but again this isn't just about this isn't just about
understanding you know is
how amazing is the system this is also about understanding what are the ineffic
iencies and then
you know for example we at the end of this session we might be able to
understand that this specific
setup was inefficient without that set up would have done an extra x amount
just removed
inefficiencies sometimes is the highest form of leverage.
you
unfortunately the infrastructure is technically from this low to this high
which either means
don't take the trade or take it based off of internal plain and simple and so
if we take it
back off internal that would be this position then it would be internal it
would also be
partially discretionary. First they point for March. Do we actually have any
those team.
Yeah we do we have retail sales and PPR. Again it's a difficult one it's like
if you take it then it's
discretionary so yeah I mean
so do you you can test for that as well but we'll just
we'll miss it because it's technically not a playbook in a market condition
would I take it
maybe but again I'm not here to tell you what it would take I'm gonna tell you
what to take with
this model so yeah the M1 shift bearish here
so yeah there's just nothing and you're not gonna get anything because the M1
isn't gonna shift
bullish oh wait it could continue to end lower let's see now you now you have a
new structure look
could trade that could trade that do we have news we do it so yeah 15
we're looking at this level lows swing high it's almost one to five basically
just playing
continuations.
you
don't want to be in this through retail sales
hmm break even anyway
it's more of a love than sweet frank
hmm
you
didn't need to
does this your news
Friday this evening with March do we have any news
sessions or the first do we miss anything there
shift bullish here
you
10th hill loss in here
price change is character here
again honestly like full objectivity there's not a way there's no chance that I
would ever take
that off of such a small sweep knowing all the context that we have above here
knowing there's
the stop-start above here as well but i'm going to take it just to show
just want to make sure that we're not however anything is inefficient
essentially
so i don't really know where to take the trade from
so
for this i've got some here again objectively like
in emerald market conditions there's no way i take this
you
that's that wouldn't be my media expectation
cool but now though
I need to stop skipping so fast
that's the law the london new york law friday 50th march
michigan and ten
um that's my shift really
mostly because it's difficult to understand whether it's a place to trade
though to be totally asked
m5
maybe just use this m1 order plot but have to cover this high because price
could definitely come up
this high and we have to stretch the tape profit as well
it's a better setup than the one before that's for sure i don't know if it's
hair so
at that point as well my stops would be
that's the brecky one
all right let's break even
the weekend
yeah also probably wouldn't be holding over the weekend anyway
this is this this is the best reason sure
i know the play was followed
we're almost an hour and a half and
we're just getting over the halfway
just a little low and then the change of character comes in
new york point of interest
empty session new york
hmm
monday 18th of monday 18th of march
boom
no
uh newsfree day
trade that if we have the criteria
in which honestly
we don't have
we need to see wait for prices for that to meet m1 criteria
now that that could count
m1 chain this character here where we answered it earlier it continues
it continues again
it respects it continues
it continues
the swing high becomes here
which price doesn't break until here
at what point we have one two three kind of a work
that we don't break
okay and then we
and then we run the highs we don't break the low
so this isn't a high
be a technically the hardest continues
and to hear
how it continues
then it breaks
then it pulls back and it breaks
then it changes character
at which point we lead us to this
and there's 445
we don't have anything in we have this in all day
overall i want to see price go to these lows
but at the same time i want to close it five rf it reaches
like a partials cool
since it's had us out yeah if it didn't then it did that cool
so we are again this is the importance as well
of just literally stick and see a plan because we're we're one we're one point
two
percent up with six weeks of trading so for this specific model this is a rough
patch
and again like i said we might come to the end of the entire testing and
understand that
there is you know inefficiencies in the model and just by removing those in
efficiencies we can
make it a whole lot better but as of right now you know this is kind of the the
period that
we're going for but what people don't realize this is what gets people and why
they have this
huge performance gap is because it only takes um it only takes a little string
of momentum
to make all the difference
go on to journal trade notes
um london sweep
point of interest still in london's lander
um
well
just consider a week
london trend is still changing character structure flows
counter period discount absolutely not news photos execution window
to new york's ash so new york i already got this week we'll put it in alone
no no
a um
hmm
but then we come back up on wicket and come back down
and then change character so here we have an interest in uh here we have an
interesting
experience where we have price puts in a high we have a three kind of pullback
and then we go to expand higher but instead of break in the high we wick the
high and then we
have another pullback and then a continuation so if i see if i was to see this
again i would use
this as a change of character because it's there's three kind of work in here
and then try
to purchase back in and breaks even the other time level before just breaking
short to the upside
i would consider this a reversal if it wasn't this love then it would have to
be
a level they don't hear anyway as well
or obviously still in normans land um but yeah m5 for me my interest is always
going to be there
so that's the end goal but i was here want to manage the position across this
i first want to see where five hours i'd also want to take profits uh
previous age of session law as well if we reached it so i'd have three targets
in mind
okay let's see we can manage this position
still break the structure
we will stops above this high so we cut off half of our risk
nice move stops above this high now this is still unlimited wait
40 run 35 let's close half of the open position
and from my next leg i probably want to be myself to break here now as well
my next leg is down here
now if we come down here but
we do that be me closing an additional 50% of the remaining position
right so not the full amount 50% of the remaining position
which means the final 50% of the remaining position would be down here
that's kind of how we scale it out if it reaches it and it does
that pretty much says everything like one trade can really genuinely make all
the difference
incredible management everything lined up nicely
but as a nurse like 8% i think
just about aggressive management as well in the losing position just
understanding like
this model you know some months might have a 25% memory but at a 16% memory in
February
although i do believe that there's optimization to be had with the system
you
let's say this is honestly more of a
so we're only sitting right now it's 23% win rate
i'm not sure why it's 23% because it's also factoring in break evens which is
annoying
oh no it's not okay open
let's keep going oh don't do this again
every time we go off
okay let's try and sort this indicator out of the shower
you
the problem is is
if we just make sure that's just triple check but i'm pretty sure we have it
this is 18th of March before
zero to four
eleven to two
and then sixty nine
that's what we was on
yeah
cool so everything was accurate
just trading view and trades that are the combination of UTC and times
this stuff i already know it could use a lot of people that's normal okay cool
let's keep
them a momentum moving so we're obviously we're obviously bearish this is a
pullback but i don't
like it again you already know me at this point you know when i'll use
discretion when i won't
at least i think you will that's not swing high for me there's no way the age
of houses
and it just doesn't happen no inside of a price like not chance so if price was
to trade higher
up in here i was still sure unless we have a pullback and continuation again uh
it's Tuesday
the 19th of March right
and we have
said it over you build impairments
yeah then we also have FOMC 25 March so the price action over the next couple
of days may be a
little bit choppy but yeah for me like just now um still uh
New York no thank London for me now like this i don't care this isn't a swing
high for me
point blank period
like that's just not
we fail to break the lows right
again for me like i just wouldn't ever trade this i don't care if there is a
setup or not there
isn't a setup anyway still wouldn't trade it for me the probability of like
this age of high being
the swing high is just like no not when it's so close different scenario maybe
if that would have broken i would have had to accept it but yeah
oh yeah that's interest rates it makes sense maybe it was just all a priming
for that
goal of public liquidity so we'll go to now to 20th right no sorry 21st
we have the h-carb of 430 when it's h-carb at 430 if you look 330 now
but then all of this is accurate
that's a work you're then it's a 430 what can i say
oh look it's a London oh wow oh wow okay froze this manner in the works
so we're obviously bullish no doubt about that we're looking for longs
it's got a two and we have a full sigh okay
um did we just become
bearish we're now bearish
oh we're bearish so we can show this i won't be showing from there though
yeah no there's no context we're not coming from a point of interest
and we're not coming from a sweep of liquidity therefore there's no trade
um
we're bearish technically again like i'm not having it like i would apply my
own discretion here but
this is not it's not a swing high i think i remember this process i think i
literally
remembered saying this wasn't a swing higher than it ended up being uh
that's also technically a pullback i'm not a huge fan of this price action
um there's nothing we can really do here
further that's 20 second of launch
nothing
nope
and then sessions done
London
so the new swing highs here
and monday 25th march
we have nothing
it's a sweep we really don't like it but it is a sweep
i prefer price to trade higher
it does okay
but never really don't like shallow sweep like that
that's undeniably shift
in birth have i you up?
sometimes it bugs out
oh maybe i was bugging out i don't know
20 shares
nothing today
probably going to tag the driving well
oh okay thank you
time is up for tag and exit
um this is technically this is a lot of sweet leisure
point of interest
strong session
London trend
trending
structure of law
inside of our trend pyramid is gone yep it was help
execution window is 45
right yeah
cool
it's four three
and sometimes that's just how the coffee grumbles
how can you do about it
okay
i want to see a sweep of these highs
we're out good old new york we do get this week
and we also get the run up it's probably not going to get a trade from here but
let's see
yeah London Sesh
we are
bullish
bush
let's try it back into
point of interest
nope
uh we shift bearish
look at shorts
shapes of these highs as well
to check the one minute structure
not sure
you
hmm
valid
so that's not really a take profit criteria but
again we'd have to see price trade all the down here
i'm fine with that given the fact that it should just look at price i think the
price
probably gonna trade but all these lows could be wrong but that'll be my
inclination
we'll see
hope it's a net gonna have an eye
huh
but this is early
no that's fine
can't complain with that
[ Pause ]
Mm. You have that sweep.
It's no reversal.
And sometimes that's just the way the game goes.
There's no real where I was getting back into the market, right?
Nope.
28.
[ Pause ]
There's a little tension here.
That's equals.
So where's the change of character there?
You tend to be below those lows.
[ Pause ]
Pre-mercis M5 by to cell, which is pretty much the M15.
Straight one to five.
And, nope.
[ Pause ]
It's not sure how it sounds like.
Mm-hmm.
Nope.
[ Pause ]
I don't know whether you're bullish or not.
Kind of neutral, I guess.
Cool.
See if New York's session can do anything for us.
[ Pause ]
Cool.
Mm-hmm.
The line entry there.
The entry's there, but now we're in the session.
In the session.
Friday, this should probably be the last day of some months.
Technically.
Technically bullish.
Mm-hmm.
It's the way we're having news.
Sorry, that's not sure.
There we go.
Cool PC.
Okay.
This is a M15.
Just shifted bullish and bullish again.
And that's that done.
And that's the 1st of April.
So, that is March complete.
We'll go back to a quick little luck.
Was it difficult?
Again, honestly difficult trading conditions.
Not the cleanest.
We're at 20% wind rate.
Across the two months now.
We are profitable.
But we really want to optimize this.
A fair amount.
Again, our Zeta score is nicer now,
but our wind rate is really what's laid us down.
Yeah, wind rate's really laid us down, to be honest with you.
Yeah, this goes to reports.
And then, let's see what our problems are.
So, you can see it's London sweep Asia.
It's not really just us at the moment.
But then what you can do is you can compare us.
And now we can go, OK, London sweep Asia is the problem.
So, we want to go London sweep Asia.
And then what else?
All right, we'll go all sides.
We'll go all the start date.
It doesn't really matter.
You're a dollar.
Same.
We want to look at this London sweep Asia.
All sides.
All winners, losers.
All right, just doesn't really matter.
All sides.
And then what else we want to look at.
And what we want to look at is
So, we want to look at
Yeah.
And then let's have a look.
At the moment in time.
There's not really what we have.
So, this is strong.
So, as of right now, coming from a strong point of interest,
we've lost five trades.
I remember my weak point of interest.
We want one trade.
Well, one percent.
Not sure exactly that's.
Oh, net one percent.
Again, it's really too early to understand this.
So, now we can see that the losses are coming between three and four am.
But it's not because that's where the trades were taken.
Not necessarily.
So, eight trades were taken between the three to four am window.
And none of them have been a winner.
But again, using this level of data is too early.
But using just the overall reports should tell us.
So, right now New York is way more profitable.
In fact, London is actually net negative as of right now.
This is how you can start seeing your problems as well if we come up to the end
of this and we see that maybe one session is negative.
One session is far insufficient and that's the session that you look at.
That's the data that you look at and then you start looking at the data.
Okay, what's inefficient about it?
What setups aren't working?
Because you can see here we've taken 15 trades in London and five trades in New
York and we've returned 13%.
In New York and our total loss is 1%.
So, we've taken five trades.
Let's go in here.
Okay.
So, what we can see here is that in New York right now.
Didn't say five trades.
Hmm.
Is that closed trades?
Let's have a look.
No, it can't be.
It's our own tag.
So, we can see the straightaway New York session.
So far, we've taken three trades with one, two, we've lost one.
So far in London, we've taken 11 trades.
We've lost 10.
One, one.
From the first affair.
Because I know there was a discretion to think it wasn't tagged, right?
So, at the moment, the issue is London.
So, we need to look at, again, not right now, at the end of this, we need to
look at where's the inefficiency coming from in London.
What setup is it, right?
And then we can kind of start reverse engineering the data from that
perspective and then start understanding what's working and what's not working.
But that's March.
Let's keep this ball rolling.
Let's keep the momentum going and then we'll understand kind of this data far
more in depth by the time that we're doing and then we'll be able to make all
the changes necessary.
to drastically change the difference of the what edges capable of.